michel fayyad analyste politique et
financier franco libanais bonjour michel
fayyad merci de répondre à nos questions
sur rt france ce sont les premiers
responsables politiques à être accusé
dans cette affaire
qu'est ce qu'ils risquent moi je pense
qu'il qu'ils risquent pas grand chose
parce qu'il ya des aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'affrontements politiques à travers la
justice à travers l'audit je vais
comptable qui concerne la banque
centrale qui va probablement s'étendre à
d'autres organismes de l'état et aux
autres ministères
donc je pense pas qu'il ira vraiment
grand chose maintenant ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que le premier
ministre actuel est mise en et enfin est
inculpé et par contre ce sont des ex
ministres qui sont inculpés et pas
d'ancien premier ministre rafic hariri
qui était premier ministre alors à quai
mais il a été premier ministre
oui saad hariri il était premier
ministre au moment des faits à samedi
avait effectivement d'autres politiques
peuvent-ils être visée également par des
procédures de la sorte en gros est ce
que c'est ouvrir la boîte de pandore
oui et non parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
pouvoir judiciaire au liban au niveau
pénal est dirigée par le procureur
général près la cour de cassation qui
s'appellera sanwi date et qui est
l'homme de saad hariri et c'est pour
cela qu'on me voit qu'il ya une certaine
en fait incertain avec le monde compte
en s'attaquant uniquement au premier
ministre démissionnaire actuel donc
hassan diab
au lieu de s'en prendre également en
plus de lui à saad hariri qui était le
premier ministre entre 2016 et 2020 et
tammam salam qui était le promu nice
entre 2014 et 2016 sachant que le
nitrate et dans le bord depuis au moins
six ans il s'agirait d'une première au
liban où des responsables à ce niveau
sera mis en cause en depuis les années
90 comment est ce que la population
libanaise réagi à cette annonce
aujourd'hui moi je pense que la
population libanaise en fait elle est
dépitée de tout ce qui se passe parce
qu'elles considèrent que en fait tous
ces gens là se tiennent mais qu'elle n'a
aucun qui va tomber que c'est là en fait
la peau la poudre de perlimpinpin qui
est lancée et qu' il faut des choses
vraiment concrètes pour changer les
choses
les choses concrètes ce sont 1 en fait
un véritable audit juricomptable au
niveau de la de la banque centrale au
niveau des ministères au niveau de tous
les organismes et d'autre part la
séparation entre la justice et le
pouvoir politique parce que comme je les
dis le la justice pénale est entre les
mains d'une personne qui est un proche
d'arrêt ne vous pouvez pas avoir des
gens d'affairé comme le directeur du
port parce que le directeur du port à
cinq corps et âme c'est un homme
d'affairé et d'autres être réellement
inculpé juger et ainsi de suite
si vous ne vous ne séparait pas ce
pouvoir judiciaire du pouvoir politique
l'explosion du port de beyrouth a révélé
l'ampleur d'un système massif de
corruption dans lequel tous les partis
politiques sera impliqué sans aucune
exception estiment les experts est ce
que ça peut expliquer le refus de mener
une enquête internationale
vous savez aussi le liban à une mauvaise
expérience en terme d' enquête
internationale parce que lorsqu'il ya
une enquête internationale en 2005 pour
l'assassinât de rafic hariri
cette enquête n'a toujours enfin en fait
le tribunal les a rendu un jugement que
cette année est en fait le liban
les sorties un peu déçu de du résultat
après avoir pourtant dépensé au moins un
milliard de dollars donc pour un pays
qui souffre de crises d'endettement etc
ont payé une enquête internationale et
en bout en bout de course être déçu ça
n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt maintenance
caire il faut vraiment qu'il ya un
changement au niveau politique libanais
comme j'ai dit une séparation du pouvoir
judiciaire et du pouvoir politique pour
que les enquêtes avaient jusqu'au bout
qu'on enquête vraiment qu'on trouve les
responsables qu'on les juge qu'il n'y
ait plus personne qu'ils soient au
dessus des lois
merci michel fayyad d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste politique et financier franco
libanais